If you've ever watched Showtime's comedy-drama
series "Shameless," you know the Gallaghers'
lives are far from ordinary.
Each character tends to end up in some unfortunate
situation that takes an entire village to
correct.
Whether it's Carl selling guns at school,
Fiona hitting her mother's corpse before her
funeral, or Frank losing his son in a bet,
taking an Alzheimer's patient hostage, or
intentionally killing a woman with a heart
condition, "Shameless" is filled with controversial
content.
Many viewers clearly found the jaw-dropping
activities depicted in "Shameless" entertaining,
as evidenced by the fact that the show ran
for 134 episodes across 11 seasons before
its finale in April 2021.
However, plenty of fans didn't love every
episode.
Some long-time viewers found certain storylines
absolutely disgusting, and many more have
said that the show crossed the line on a number
of occasions.
Examples of "Shameless" moments that left
viewers uneasy and even outraged include Veronica
convincing her mother to sleep with her boyfriend
so she could have a child for them and Frank
making his own son Carl believe that he has
cancer.
Of course, there are many more over-the-top
"Shameless" moments that we won't get into
here.
"Debbie stole a baby.
We have to figure out how to return it."
But many fans believe one scene in the Season
4 episode "There's the Rub" went way too far.
In the episode, it's Fiona's birthday, which
should be a joyous celebration.
However, this is Fiona Gallagher we're talking
about, so there's bound to be some drama involved.
Her boyfriend Mike ends up dumping her because
she's having an affair with his brother Robbie.
The everyday chaos of a "Shameless" episode
ensues, including fights, drinking, and partying.
Towards the end of the episode, Robbie gives
Fiona a birthday present: a little bag of
drugs.
Fiona kicks Robbie out, but leaves the bag
on the table.
She eventually shares the drugs during her
party.
Unfortunately, the youngest Gallagher brother,
Liam, finds the drugs and ingests some.
Debbie finds Liam unconscious in the other
room and calls Fiona for help, but it seems
like it's too late.
The young boy is passed out with white powder
all over his face.
The paramedics are called, and Fiona is arrested
for child abuse and possession of an illegal
substance.
Liam ends up recovering from the overdose,
but doctors warn he may experience learning
disabilities moving forward.
Although this kind of thing isn't completely
unexpected in the series, it still doesn't
make it any easier to witness.
Many viewers felt that this depiction of child
abuse and endangerment was too much, even
for a show like "Shameless."
Fiona's mistakes didn't start at disrespecting
her dead mother and stop at endangering her
little brother.
Over the course of the series' 11 seasons,
nine of which Fiona actress Emmy Rossum starred
in, she did a lot of questionable things,
and fans had no problem airing their grievances
about the character.
One Reddit user admitted that he likes "Shameless"
but finds the Gallagher family terrible — particularly
Fiona, for a number of reasons.
The Redditor wrote…
"Fiona is ridiculous.
She's cheated on pretty much all of her boyfriends
and is controlling of everyone around her.
[...] The only thing she did that could be
considered good is raising her siblings and
even then she has to lord it over anyone who
will listen.
And she never seems to show remorse for what
she does."
"I'm not just chaos."
Another viewer and Redditor pointed out that
when Rossum left "Shameless," it brought Fiona's
core storyline to an end at the perfect moment.
"Fiona left at the right place and the right
time IMO.
Her role as acting guardian was more or less
fulfilled.
By the time she asks Ian for permission to
leave, it's strikingly obvious that she is
no longer needed."
Not all "Shameless" fans feel this way, of
course.
Even in the face of all Fiona has done wrong,
plenty of viewers still think she deserves
a lot of credit for doing all she could to
take care of her family.
One Redditor wrote...
"Fiona gets so much s--- but I think she is
one of the best characters in the show.
She's got the most empathy out of all the
Gallaghers for her family and will do anything
to help them whenever they need it.
She deserves the world despite her awful mistakes
with her significant others and Liam."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Shameless
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.